They can laugh about it now, the Ohm family. It was Thanksgiving dinner, suburban Minneapolis, big spread, pumpkins on the table, 14 people, and it was 2002, a year after 9/11.
奥姆一家现在可以拿这件事开玩笑了。那是2002年的感恩节晚餐，地点在明尼阿波利斯郊区，摆着丰盛的菜肴和南瓜，有14个人，当时距离9/11事件已经过去一年了。
We were all just talking about 9/11, just 9/11 anything.
我们当时都在聊9/11，聊跟9/11有关的任何事情。
This is Alexis, the baby of the family. She and her parents came into our studio and talked with one of our show's producers, Alex Blumberg.
这位是亚历克西斯，家里最小的孩子。她和父母来到我们的演播室，与我们的一位节目制作人亚历克斯·布伦伯格进行了交谈。
And one of the topics that was brought up was Osama bin Laden, and I just for some reason just said I thought he was attractive. I thought he was hot. And my dad really didn't appreciate that comment.
谈话中提到了奥萨马·本·拉登，不知怎么地，我随口说了一句我觉得他很有魅力，我觉得他很帅。我爸当时对这个评论非常不满。
I wasn't going to listen to any of it. I really wasn't. I mean, I wasn't going to let any comment like that about his looks get one inch further out of her mouth. I'll say to this day, it was ridiculous.
我当时根本不想听任何解释。我真的不想。我是说，我绝不会让这种关于他长相的言论从她嘴里再说出一个字。即使到了今天，我还是要说，这太荒唐了。
What did your father say?
你父亲说了什么？
I think he told me to [BLEEP] off.
我想他让我滚一边去。
That had never happened before. Alexis looked at her two little cousins, Henry and Hugo, who didn't know how to react. Her mom Diane didn't know how to react.
以前从没发生过这种事。亚历克西斯看着她两个年幼的表亲亨利和雨果，他们不知该作何反应。她的母亲黛安也不知所措。
I just my whole meal that I had spent a week preparing kind of going up in flames with that statement. The minute the F-bomb landed, I thought, well now, what am I going to do? There sat these two precious little boys, and their eyes were as big as saucers, and I had to do something, anything to smooth this horrible situation over. So I think I probably said something like, well, you know what? He does kind of look like Jesus, the long hair. Just to smooth it over, that's what I remember myself saying.
我花了一周时间准备的整顿饭，就因为这句话而毁了。就在脏话出口的那一刻，我想，天哪，现在我该怎么办？那两个可爱的小男孩坐在那里，眼睛瞪得像铜铃一样大，我必须做点什么，任何事都行，来缓和这个糟糕的局面。所以我可能说了类似的话：好吧，你知道吗？他长得确实有点像耶稣，留着长发。为了圆场，我记得我当时就是这么说的。
Yeah, needless to say, comparing Osama bin Laden to Jesus didn't exactly smooth things over.
是的，不用说，把奥萨马·本·拉登比作耶稣并没有起到缓和作用。
Then we all just started yelling.
然后我们大家都开始大喊大叫。
Yeah, I probably went to about 250 degrees, because I just--
是的，我当时的火气大概飙到了250度，因为我只是——
I think you got out of your chair.
我觉得你从椅子上站起来了。
I think I got out of my chair, I really did. I said, if that's the best we can come up with after what's happened to our country, boy, I'll tell you.
我想我确实站起来了。我说，如果这就是在我们国家发生那种事后我们能想出来的最好结论，天哪，我真是无话可说。
He was going off. And when Jeff goes off, we all listen. I do remember him saying something horrible, like I think the Middle East should be made into a parking lot.
他彻底爆发了。当杰夫爆发时，我们都会听着。我确实记得他说了一些可怕的话，比如我想中东应该被改造成一个停车场。
I don't think I ever said that.
我不认为我说过那种话。
I think you do that day.
我觉得你那天说了。
No, I know I didn't.
不，我知道我没说。
Yes, you did.
你说了。
I guess in retrospect, my reaction, I regret what I said. But I had to get my point across. I just for some reason had no appreciation for what Osama bin Laden looked like. This guy, I don't care what he looks like. I don't care if he looked like Paul Newman. He's still responsible for what he did. The looks thing, it just jacked me right there.
我想回顾一下，我对自己说的话感到后悔。但我必须表达我的观点。不知为何，我无法理解奥萨马·本·拉登的长相有什么可说的。这家伙，我不在乎他长什么样。我不在乎他看起来是不是像保罗·纽曼。他仍然要为他所做的一切负责。关于长相的那种言论，直接把我给激怒了。
Alexis pretty much knew what she was getting into to talk about Osama bin Laden this way with her dad. He is conservative and served in the army. She knew what kind of room she was working. But she hadn't really factored in the fact that it was Thanksgiving dinner. Her dad says that's a lot of what made it blow up.
亚历克西斯很清楚，如果和父亲讨论奥萨马·本·拉登，会引发什么样的后果。他是个保守派，曾在军队服役。她知道自己面对的是什么样的人。但她确实没考虑到这是在感恩节晚餐上。她父亲说，这正是导致冲突升级的原因。
That was just the wrong place at the wrong time. It really was. I think the tension of Thanksgiving, getting the food all on the table, getting prepared, getting going. And then all of a sudden, here we go.
那只是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。真的。我想是感恩节的紧张气氛，把食物端上桌，筹备一切，忙忙碌碌。然后突然间，就这样了。
Today on our show, we have stories of people facing various kinds of tough rooms, trying to calculate what they're going to say, what they can get away with, and usually not getting the reactions they figured they were going to get.
今天我们的节目中，我们要讲一些人面临各种艰难场面的故事，他们试图计算自己该说什么，能蒙混过关说什么，但通常得到的结果与他们预想的并不一样。
WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our program today, Tough Room in four tough acts. Act one, Make 'Em Laff, in which we go among comedy professionals who face a room that is so tough, there's just one laugh every 100 jokes. Act two, Bar Car Prophecy. A young person tries to hang out in a tough room full of adults, adults and booze.
今天的节目，四幕关于艰难局面的故事。第一幕，“让他们笑”，我们走访了一群喜剧专业人士，他们面对的场面非常冷清，每100个笑话里只有一个能引起笑声。第二幕，“酒吧车厢的预言”。一个年轻人试图混入一个全是成年人、充满酒精的艰难场合。
Act three, Mission Impossible. At the doorsteps to one of the great secular temples to science ever built, New York's Museum of Natural History, two Mormon missionaries work a very tough sidewalk as they try to bring unbelievers over to their way of seeing things. Act four, Tough Newsroom. Writer Malcolm Gladwell remembers getting a newspaper job with no experience, and no real idea of how to write for a newspaper. Stay with us.
第三幕，“不可能的任务”。在人类有史以来最伟大的科学殿堂之一——纽约自然历史博物馆的台阶前，两名摩门教传教士在一条非常艰难的街道上工作，试图引导不信者接受他们的观点。第四幕，“艰难的新闻编辑室”。作家马尔科姆·格拉德威尔回忆了他如何在毫无经验、也完全不知道如何为报纸撰稿的情况下获得了一份记者的工作。留下来，听我们慢慢道来。
Act one, Make 'Em Laff. There are tough rooms for salesmen, and tough rooms for politicians, and tough rooms for teachers, and grant applicants, and job interviewees, and doctoral students taking their orals. But I think the classic tough room, the tough room that defines them all, is when a comedian stands in front of a silent audience, delivering one joke after another, and getting nothing back whatsoever. And there's no tougher audience than other comedians.
第一幕，“让他们笑”。对推销员来说有艰难的场合，对政客、老师、奖学金申请人、求职者和参加口试的博士生来说也有艰难的场合。但我认为，定义所有艰难场面的经典例子，是一位喜剧演员站在沉默的观众面前，一个接一个地讲着笑话，却得不到任何回应。而没有比面对其他喜剧演员更艰难的听众了。
All right, here we go. Global warming proven by one 50-degree day in January. Area man just wants to know if he should cancel his annual Oscars party or not. Nation guesses it will have the chicken Caesar salad.
好了，开始吧。全球变暖被一月里那一天50度的气温证明了。当地男子只想知道他是否该取消一年一度的奥斯卡派对。全国猜想它会是鸡肉凯撒沙拉。
It's Monday morning in the offices of The Onion , and to start the new issue, each of the writers has brought in a list of 15 headlines for their fake news newspaper. There are eight people at the table, seven men and one woman, which is par for the course in the comedy business, almost all of them in their 20s. Seth Reiss goes first. He's just 24, been at the paper for two years. And the way it works is, if Seth can convince two people to vote for a headline, it survives one more day until the next round of editing.
这是《洋葱报》办公室的周一早晨，为了新一期报纸，每位撰稿人都带来了一份15条假新闻头条的列表。桌子旁有八个人，七男一女，这在喜剧行业是常态，他们几乎都在20多岁。塞思·赖斯先开始。他才24岁，已经在报社工作两年了。规则是，如果塞思能说服两个人为他的头条投票，它就能存活到下一轮编辑会议。
Star of David to add seventh point.
大卫之星将增加第七个角。
Sure.
没问题。
Report: America runs on--
报道：美国运行在——
I'm sorry. It got enough votes, I just didn't understand why that was funny, and I was going to ask for it but I--
抱歉。它获得了足够的票数，但我只是不明白为什么这很有趣，我本来想问问，但我——
I just think it's silly.
我觉得它很傻。
OK. I'm just saying.
好吧，我只是说说。
The joke survives. Seth marks it with a highlighter. I came here because, by the time they're done with this process, The Onion is one of the most reliably funny things out there. And I heard that one of the reasons for that was this room. This was a very tough room, with a tough minded editorial process that they've been using for 20 years, and I wanted to see what that meant.
这个笑话存活了下来。塞思用荧光笔做了标记。我之所以来到这里，是因为经过这个过程，当《洋葱报》发布时，它是最可靠的笑料来源之一。我听说原因之一就是这个房间。这是一个非常严苛的环境，有着他们坚持了20年的严苛编辑流程，我想看看这意味着什么。
Car commercial pretty adamant about car.
汽车广告对汽车相当坚持。
Yeah.
是的。
Class struggle a breeze for local investment banker. Todd? [LAUGHTER]
阶级斗争对当地投资银行家来说是小菜一碟。托德？[笑声]
Now you're just calling out who you want to vote for them? That's not right.
现在你是在点名你想让谁投票吗？那是不对的。
Though it's incredibly popular, with three quarters of a million copies in print each week plus 5 million individual visitors at the website every month, it's possible that, especially if you're older, you've never actually read The Onion . So here's what you need to know. It's written in newspaper form, though lots of the funniest stories aren't really news parody, but just everyday life described in a deadpan newspaper style, like "Stoners announce plans to get stoned for that," or "Rejection letter silently flipped off," or "Control of anecdote wrested from boyfriend." These were all considered for this one issue, by the way.
虽然它极其受欢迎，每周印刷量达75万份，每月网站访问量达500万，但如果你年龄较大，可能从未真正读过《洋葱报》。所以你需要知道这些：它以报纸的形式编写，尽管许多最有趣的故事并非真正的新闻模仿，而是用冷淡的新闻风格描述的日常生活，比如“瘾君子宣布计划为此吸毒”，或者“拒绝信被默默竖起中指”，或者“轶事控制权从男友手中夺回”。顺便说一句，这些都是这一期考虑过的题材。
The younger staffers say that it's hard not to take what happens in this room personally sometimes. Seth Reiss tells me that he's made a resolution to stop muttering under his breath, you're all wrong, when the group rejects his headlines, because after all, they can't all be wrong. Megan Ganz, who is 23 and who has been at the paper for a year and a half, says it can be a blow, and it smarts when a headline that you're sure of, that you love, doesn't make the cut.
年轻的员工们说，有时候很难不把房间里发生的事情个人化。塞思·赖斯告诉我，他已下定决心停止喃喃自语“你们都错了”，当小组否决他的头条时，因为毕竟，他们不可能都错。23岁且已在报社工作了一年半的梅根·甘茨说，这可能是一个打击，当你确信、热爱的一个头条被毙掉时，确实会让人心痛。
That happens a lot. And then all of that work just evaporates into nothing. There are headlines that I remember pitching that I think I know that they're not any good, but some part of my heart is like attached to them. Like I had this one that was, "Spork used as knife." And for some reason that was like the funniest thing I thought I'd ever thought of, was the fact that here's a utensil that's two utensils, and you're using it as the only utensil it isn't. And it didn't even get a titter in the meeting. Nothing, it just died. And I read it twice, and they were like, yeah, move on. Still, that must have been this summer. It was like months ago that I wrote that headline. I still think about it.
这种情况经常发生。然后所有的努力都化为乌有。我记得我提出过一些头条，我知道它们并不好，但我心里的一部分对它们产生了感情。比如我曾写过一条：“叉勺被用作刀子”。出于某种原因，这被我认为是有史以来最有趣的创意，因为这里有一种本身是两种餐具合体的工具，而你却把它用作唯一不该用它的方式。结果会议上连一丝笑声都没有。什么都没有，它直接胎死腹中。我读了两遍，他们说，好吧，继续。但这一定是在这个夏天。那都是几个月前写下的头条了。我现在还在想它。
World's most depressing technical college creates world's most depressing bus ad. It's a slight variation on one that I've--
世界上最压抑的技术学院创造了世界上最压抑的公交广告。这是我曾做过的一点小改动——
I still like that.
我还是喜欢那个。
I like that one.
我喜欢那个。
OK.
好吧。
The highlighter is passed to Todd Hanson, who's not just the oldest person at the table, he's been at The Onion longer than anybody else. He started in 1990 when The Onion wasn't really a business, but more of a hobby for a few friends who all worked crappy jobs elsewhere to support themselves. In these meetings, he tends to talk the most, partly out of seniority, and partly, as he admits, because he just can't be any other way. Though when he reads his list, he's just like any of the other writers. And this is really the damnedest thing about their jobs. Even with all his years of experience, even he can't tell which of his brand new jokes is any good.
荧光笔传给了托德·汉森，他不仅是桌上年纪最大的人，也是在《洋葱报》工作时间最长的人。他始于1990年，当时《洋葱报》还不是一家企业，更像是几个朋友的业余爱好，他们都在别处做着烂工作来养活自己。在这些会议中，他往往说得最多，部分是因为资历，部分如他所承认的，是因为他就是这样的人。尽管当他阅读自己的列表时，他和任何其他撰稿人一样。这真的是他们工作中极其残酷的一点。即使拥有多年的经验，他自己也无法判断他的哪个新笑话是好的。
Man evidently thinks those sideburns make him look cool. It's not funny.
男的明显以为那些鬓角让他看起来很酷。这不好笑。
I kind of like that.
我倒有点喜欢这个。
Really?
真的吗？
Kind of.
算是吧。
Is it funny with something other than sideburns?
除了鬓角，还有什么有趣的吗？
Sideburns?
鬓角？
No? OK, all right. Pornography desensitized populace demands new orifice to look at.
没有？好吧，行。色情片让民众变得麻木，要求看新的孔洞。
Yes.
可以。
OK. Area man not technically pathetic in that he fails to elicit pathos.
好吧。当地男子在未能激起怜悯方面，在技术上并不算可悲。
But are you just making a joke about how people incorrectly use the word pathetic?
但你是不是在拿人们错误使用“可悲”这个词开玩笑？
It takes them two long mornings, on Monday and on Tuesday, to come up with these 16 headlines they're going to use in the paper this week. And to get to those 16, they go through-- and I know this number is going to sound kind of crazy-- 600 possible headlines.
他们花了两个漫长的上午，周一和周二，才敲定本周报纸要用的这16个头条。为了得到这16个，他们要过——我知道这个数字听起来很疯狂——600个备选头条。
OK, this is a sad joke that comes straight from real life. Casual relationship enters third year.
好吧，这是一个直接源于现实生活的悲伤笑话。随意关系进入第三年。
So that's still going on? [LAUGHTER] Sorry. I'm sorry. That wasn't to be mean, that was a legitimate question, because we've talked about it before.
所以那个还在继续？[笑声] 抱歉。我很抱歉。那不是为了刻薄，那是一个合理的问题，因为我们之前谈过这个。
Truthfully, the staff is a lot nicer to each other than I figured they'd be. Comedians can be incredibly competitive, and The Onion has gone through phases when the chemistry wasn't so chill. But mainly, they're just tough on the material. It's a  tough room because of how minutely they dissect all the jokes. Over the years, they've developed a way of discussing the material that helps them decide whether something is so outstandingly funny, it beats a lot of other jokes that are also pretty funny, and what makes each joke funny, and how to make it funnier. As an outsider, and not privy to these shared assumptions and what one of them called their hive mentality, it's sometimes hard to figure out why, for instance, "Local girlfriend always wants to do stuff" was a good enough headline to make it into the paper, while a headline that seems nearly identical, "Nation's girlfriends call for more quality time," literally gets jeers. Jeers. Listen.
说实话，员工们彼此之间比我想象的要友善得多。喜剧演员之间竞争可能非常激烈，《洋葱报》也经历过气氛不那么轻松的阶段。但主要还是因为他们对素材要求严苛。这是一个艰难的房间，因为他们对所有笑话的拆解非常细致。多年来，他们发展出一种讨论素材的方式，帮助他们决定某件事是否优秀到足以胜过其他同样有趣的笑话，以及是什么让每个笑话变得有趣，如何让它更有趣。作为一个局外人，不了解这些共同假设以及其中一人所说的“蜂群心态”，有时很难弄清楚为什么，例如，“当地女友总是想做点什么”是一个足够好的头条，可以登上报纸，而一个看起来几乎一模一样的“全国女友呼吁更多高质量时间”，却遭到了嘲笑。嘲笑。听着。
Nation's girlfriends call for more quality time.
全国女友呼吁更多高质量时间。
Or nation's wives spend all the husband's money on expensive hats. Coming home with another round shaped box. Look at that stack of round boxes.
或者全国的妻子把丈夫的钱全花在昂贵的帽子上。带着另一个圆形盒子回家。看看那一堆圆形盒子。
I'm pregnant.
我怀孕了。
Lucy?
露西？
Or why does this joke get immediate, unquestioning approval?
或者为什么这个笑话获得了立即、毫无质疑的批准？
Beauty regimen horrifying.
美容疗法令人恐惧。
Yes.
是的。
Yes, definitely. That's funny.
是的，绝对。那很有趣。
While the headline "Roommate's unopened bag of Doritos taunting area man" deserved a long discussion over whether the point of the joke was in fact the taunting.
而头条“室友未开封的多力多滋让当地男子受到挑衅”，在“笑话的重点是否真的是挑衅”这一点上引发了长时间的讨论。
The reason it's funny is because the word taunting--
有趣的原因是因为“挑衅”这个词——
Like he's been staring at it from a distance of 15 feet from his couch for the past 10 minutes.
就像他过去10分钟一直从沙发上15英尺远的地方盯着它看一样。
Or do the Doritos themselves make the joke too obvious?
或者多力多滋本身让笑话太明显了吗？
It would be funny, and it would have funny details in it, but on its immediate surface, it's a joke about Doritos, and like a food item--
这会很有趣，也会有有趣的细节，但从表面上看，这是一个关于多力多滋和某种食物的笑话——
I agree that Doritos is an immediate go-to kind of snack. Is there another snack it could be?
我同意多力多滋是一种直接的选择。还有其他零食可以替代吗？
I mean Doritos is the exact right product.
我的意思是多力多滋是完全正确的产品。
Watching them parse jokes like this, with a kind of academic precision that they're sort of proud of, hour after hour, it's not just tedious, it's the opposite of comedy. And the other thing that was very odd watching them work, was that most of the jokes that got the biggest laughs from the writers themselves did not make it into the paper. For example, this headline.
看着他们像对待学术研究一样极其精确地剖析笑话，一小时接一小时，这不仅乏味，简直是喜剧的反面。另一件看他们工作时非常奇怪的事情是，大多数在撰稿人自己中间引发最大笑声的笑话，都没能登上报纸。例如，这个头条。
Cardinal teaches pope to make church by interlocking his fingers.
红衣主教教教皇通过交叉手指来制作教堂。
Or this one.
或者这个。
Gay retard teased. [LAUGHTER]
同性恋弱智被嘲笑。[笑声]
That one's great.
那个很棒。
That's so awful.
那太糟糕了。
Or here's another.
或者这里还有另一个。
Infertile woman treats frog shaped humidifier as human child. [LAUGHTER]
不孕妇女把青蛙造型的加湿器当成人类孩子。[笑声]
And what the hell? Let's just do one more.
还有，管他呢？我们再做一个吧。
Biologist realizes he's been studying Cadbury egg.
生物学家意识到他一直在研究吉百利彩蛋。
After the meeting, I get explanations for the many mysterious decisions I've witnessed. I'm told that usually the jokes that get laughs on Monday do not survive. Again, Megan Ganz.
会议结束后，我得到了我所目睹的许多神秘决定的解释。我被告知，通常周一引起笑声的笑话并不能存活。还是梅根·甘茨。
A lot of the jokes that we laugh really hard at don't make it in the paper, because they're just like initially funny, but then we sit down on Tuesday and go, well what does that mean though? What will we say about that? Where does that joke go? There was a headline once that everyone laughed at really hard, that was "Woman crying by penguin exhibit." Do you guys remember this headline? "Woman sobbing near penguin exhibit." And everyone laughed really hard, and then everyone went, OK, but why is that funny? It's funny because it's penguins, I guess, and like women crying is kind of a weird thing to be happening near them. But then nobody would pitch that on a Tuesday meeting as being funny, even though it made everyone laugh. Nobody would pitch that, because what do you write about that? It doesn't go anywhere.
很多我们笑得很开心的笑话都没能进入报纸，因为它们只是起初有趣，但到了周二我们坐下来时，会觉得，好吧，那意味着什么呢？我们能说些什么？那个笑话要去哪里？曾经有一个所有人都笑得很厉害的头条，“妇女在企鹅展区哭泣”。你们还记得这个头条吗？“妇女在企鹅展区附近啜泣”。大家笑得特别开心，然后大家都说，OK，但这为什么有趣？是因为企鹅，我想，妇女在它们附近哭泣是一件很奇怪的事情。但后来没有人会在周二的会议上把它作为有趣的东西提出，即使它让所有人都笑了。没有人会提出，因为你能写些什么呢？它没法展开。
And then there's this mystery. Why did the story "Local girlfriend always wants to do stuff" make the paper, while "Nation's girlfriends call for more quality time" got heckled. Todd Hanson and Dan Guterman explain that the story that went with "Local girlfriend always wants to do stuff" was actually written in a way that made fun of the guy in the relationship.
还有这个谜团。为什么“当地女友总是想做点什么”这个故事登上了报纸，而“全国女友呼吁更多高质量时间”却遭到了起哄。托德·汉森和丹·古特曼解释说，配合“当地女友总是想做点什么”的故事实际上是用一种嘲讽这段关系中男方的方式编写的。
In talking about what a sort of lowly loser he is for being irked by his girlfriend's desire to do things. It's just more like, she's always wanting to go do stuff, and be around people. And she always wants to leave the house.
谈论他作为一个因为女友想做事而感到恼火的卑微失败者是多么可怜。这更像是，她总是想出去做事，想和人在一起。她总是想离开家。
And that seemed more original and different to us, whereas nation girlfriends-- what was it?
这在我们看来更原创、更不同，而全国女友——那是什么？
Call for more quality time.
呼吁更多高质量时间。
Just seemed like a joke about nagging girlfriends.
看起来只是一个关于唠叨女友的笑话。
And the problem with a joke about nagging girlfriends isn't the political correctness of it, but simply it's a really tired joke.
关于唠叨女友的笑话的问题不在于政治正确性，而仅仅是因为它是一个非常老套的笑话。
It's a really tired joke.
这是一个非常老套的笑话。
In fact, all through their editorial meanings, they're talking constantly about what jokes are tired. A joke about the Green Party and marijuana brownies was killed partly because mentioning the Green Party at all seemed passe. A headline about Nicole Richie's new baby, "Nicole Richie thinks baby looks fat," was ditched on the theory that any Nicole Richie fat or anorexia reference was very 2005. But one area where tastes differ on the staff is when it comes to silliness. They're for silliness, sometimes. Take the joke, "Scientist realizes he's been studying Cadbury egg" that got such a big laugh on Monday. It's just a silly joke, says Megan.
事实上，在他们的编辑讨论中，他们不断谈论哪些笑话是老套的。一个关于绿党和大麻布朗尼的笑话被毙掉，部分原因是提到绿党似乎已经过时了。一个关于妮可·里奇新孩子的头条，“妮可·里奇认为婴儿看起来很胖”，被抛弃了，理论是任何关于妮可·里奇肥胖或厌食症的引用都非常2005年。但员工在审美上的一个差异在于“傻气”。有时候他们支持傻气。拿那个在周一引发巨大笑声的“科学家意识到他一直在研究吉百利彩蛋”的笑话来说。梅根说，这只是一个傻气的笑话。
Like, we do silly jokes, granted. But it just doesn't have that X factor of being silly and kind of compelling. I don't know, it doesn't have-- I can't explain what the difference is between that one and we ran one that was "Thirsty mayor drinks town's entire water supply." And that one, we had the same reaction when it was read. We laughed really hard. And then it went in the paper. And why is that one sillier and in a better way than the other one is silly? It's funny because it's almost always agreed upon in the meetings.
比如，我们确实做傻气的笑话，可以承认。但它缺乏那种既傻气又引人注目的X因素。我不确定，它没有——我无法解释那个笑话和我们刊登的“口渴的市长喝光了全镇的供水”之间有什么区别。那一个，我们在朗读时也有同样的反应。我们笑得很大声。然后它就上了报纸。为什么那一个比另一个更傻气，且方式更好？因为它在会议中几乎总是达成一致。
Almost, but not quite. When Todd Hanson and I sat down for an interview, he spontaneously brought up the exact same headline Megan had mentioned, but to make a very different point.
几乎，但不完全。当托德·汉森和我坐下来接受采访时，他自发地提到了梅根提到的同一个头条，但为了阐述一个完全不同的观点。
No, no, don't get me wrong. I like the silly jokes. I just have to think them through and find out what they're saying. Like I remember there was a joke, "Thirsty mayor drinks entire town's water supply." And I just kept saying, why? What is it? Thirsty guy drinks a whole lake? Like what's funny about that? That's just silly in a way that isn't funny. And they're like, no, no, you got to trust us. It's funny because he's the thirsty mayor, he drinks the whole town. And they were trying to explain it to me, and I just didn't get it. And then finally, it clicked in my head, and I said, oh I get it. It's about misappropriation of public resources by a corrupt ruling oligarchy, or whatever. And then everyone made fun of me, like oh yeah, that's what it's about. It's not just silly. Well, of course it's silly, but it has something to say, and that's why it's funny. That's what I think.
不，不，别误解我。我喜欢傻气的笑话。我只是需要仔细思考它们，弄清楚它们在说什么。比如我记得有一个笑话，“口渴的市长喝光了全镇的供水”。我一直在问，为什么？这是什么？口渴的家伙喝掉整个湖？那有什么有趣的？那只是一种不好笑的傻气。他们说，不，不，你得相信我们。这很有趣，因为他是口渴的市长，他喝光了整个镇。他们试着向我解释，我就是没明白。最后，我脑中闪过一个念头，我说，哦，我明白了。它是关于一个腐败统治寡头对公共资源的滥用，或者什么的。然后所有人都嘲笑我，哦对了，就是这个意思。它不仅仅是傻气。好吧，当然它是傻气的，但它有话要说，这就是它有趣的原因。我是这么认为的。
I just don't think jokes that don't have anything to say are that funny. If you can't find something legitimate to say within the context of the joke, no matter how silly it is, I don't see the point of it.
我就是觉得没话可说的笑话没那么有趣。如果在笑话的语境下找不到什么合法的言论，无论它有多傻，我都看不出它的意义所在。
In fact, to sort this out, a whole language has emerged over the years at The Onion to talk about whether something is too silly, or silly in the wrong way. Writers speak about a joke taking them to Silly Town, or Crazyville, or Sillytown Heights, which is either good or bad depending on the person. And it can be bad, though it's usually good, when something is called a laffer. That's laffer with two f's. A laffer is a big dumb joke that you have to laugh at. If the photo that accompanies a story is a sandwich holding a press conference, that's a laffer. And the whole story is a laffertunity.
事实上，为了理清这些，多年来《洋葱报》出现了一整套话语来讨论某件事是否太傻，或者以错误的方式傻气。撰稿人谈论一个笑话把他们带到了“傻气镇”、“疯狂镇”或“傻气高地”，这取决于人，是好是坏。当某件事被称为“大傻梗”时，通常是好的，尽管可能是坏的。那是用两个f的“laffer”。“大傻梗”就是一个你不得不笑的巨大愚蠢笑话。如果故事配的照片是一块正在召开新闻发布会的三明治，那就是一个“大傻梗”。而整个故事就是一个“傻梗机遇”。
Laffers are often the most emailed stories, the most popular things that The Onion does. And while everybody on staff likes both silly jokes and jokes with a bigger meaning, a few of the younger writers definitely have more tolerance for jokes that are purely silly, and a different vision for what should go in the paper. And there are a couple times during the editorial meetings that I watched where the two sides squared off against each other. At one point, they were discussing two headlines that covered very familiar ground at The Onion . "Plan to stay in all weekend and play video games goes off smoothly," and "Area man makes it through day." Seth, one of the newest staffers, and Todd, the oldest, saw these very differently.
“大傻梗”通常是传播最广、最受欢迎的《洋葱报》内容。虽然员工中的每个人都喜欢傻气的笑话和带有深意的笑话，但少数年轻撰稿人对纯粹傻气的笑话绝对有更高的容忍度，对报纸应该登什么有不同的看法。在我观看的编辑会议期间，有几次双方发生了对抗。有一次，他们讨论了两个在《洋葱报》非常熟悉的题材头条。“计划整个周末待在家里玩电子游戏进展顺利”和“当地男子度过了一天”。塞思，最新员工之一，和托德，年纪最大的，对这些有着非常不同的看法。
Especially the video game one seems very Onion by the numbers.
尤其是电子游戏那个，看起来非常《洋葱报》风格。
That's kind of why I liked it.
那就是我为什么喜欢它的原因。
I know. But almost to a point where it's like that sentiment, I don't think we're doing anything new there.
我知道。但几乎到了某种地步，就像那种情绪，我不认为我们在那上面做了任何新的东西。
I don't know, I just think that that is The Onion's ethos. That's kind of like what The Onion is about. That's what America is--
我不确定，我只是认为那是《洋葱报》的精神。那就是《洋葱报》的本质。那就是美国——
I feel like you've done that joke before.
我觉得你以前做过那个笑话。
The reason we've done that joke before is American has been like that for a long time, and it still is.
我们以前做过那个笑话的原因是美国长期以来一直如此，而且现在依然如此。
But the sentiment is so similar to the sentiment of a lot of Onion headlines that people aren't going to notice that. They're just going to be like, oh, The Onion does this again. It just doesn't feel right to me.
但这种情绪与许多《洋葱报》头条的情绪太相似了，人们不会注意到这一点。他们只会觉得，哦，《洋葱报》又来了。这对我来说感觉不对。
I'm going to keep writing jokes like that till the day I die. So I'm just warning you.
我死之前都会一直写那种笑话。所以先警告你。
At the heart of this dispute is a problem that comes up in any creative project that lasts even a few years. You don't want to become a parody of yourself. You don't want to keep repeating the same things over and over. And yet, there are some things that you do a lot of, that are just built into the DNA of what you make. This is definitely something that we struggle with here on our radio show. And in fact, The Onion once did an article that made fun of us for rehashing certain kinds of stories, which was funny, and it stung.
在这个争端的背后，是一个在任何持续几年以上的创意项目中都会出现的问题。你不想成为自己的模仿者。你不想一遍又一遍地重复同样的事情。然而，有一些你常做的事情，是你制造内容的DNA的一部分。这绝对是我们在这里的广播节目中也苦苦挣扎的事情。事实上，《洋葱报》曾经写过一篇文章嘲笑我们反复炒作某些类型的故事，这很有趣，也很刺耳。
Megan Ganz says that as one of the newer writers on staff, she worries sometimes that they're just repeating the same jokes over and over with different words. There's one, for instance, where a big government institution just acts like your schmo college roommate, like "Syria attends Mideast peace talks for free continental breakfast." Funny, but it's a formula.
梅根·甘茨说，作为员工中较新的撰稿人，她有时担心他们只是用不同的词汇一遍又一遍地重复同样的笑话。例如，有一个，大政府机构表现得像你那个混吃混喝的大学室友，比如“叙利亚参加中东和平会谈以获得免费欧陆式早餐”。有趣，但这是一个套路。
And now, they have with the youngs and olds, the promise is all of the young people grew up reading the stuff that the older people wrote. So we formed our sense of humor on The Onion , and then became writers for The Onion. You're trying to write for your idols. It's strange. It's strange for us. We've talked about it many times, the young people here, it's strange for us to write for your idols.
现在，他们有了年轻人和老人，承诺是所有的年轻人都是读着老一辈人写的东西长大的。所以我们在《洋葱报》形成了幽默感，然后成为了《洋葱报》的撰稿人。你试图为你的偶像写作。这很奇怪。这很奇怪。我们年轻人在这里讨论过很多次，为偶像写作对我们来说很奇怪。
But also are you saying to Todd, who's been here forever, like yeah, you can't do that again. Don't do that joke again. I'm tired of that joke.
但你是不是在对托德说，他在这里待了太久，比如是的，你不能再那样做了。别再写那个笑话了。我已经厌倦了那个笑话。
That is really horrible, isn't it? So I've been trying to mimic him throughout my life to get to where I am. And now that I'm where I am, I'm like, don't do what you do.
那真的很可怕，不是吗？所以我一生都在试图模仿他，才有了今天。而现在我到了今天的位置，我却说，别做你做的事。
In the end, "Area man makes it through day" makes it onto a list of stories that will appear in upcoming issues of The Onion , partly because the founder and editor in chief of the paper, Scott Dikkers, liked it. But this disagreement wan't even close to the biggest fight they've all had lately. That fight, I'm told, was over the headline "Ghost just dropped by to say boo." One group 100% hated it, one group 100% loved it. People raised their voices. One usually mild mannered editor walked out in protest.
最后，“当地男子度过了一天”登上了将在《洋葱报》未来几期出现的故事列表，部分原因是该报的创始人兼主编斯科特·迪克斯喜欢它。但这个分歧甚至不是他们最近发生过的最大的争执。我被告知，那场争执是因为头条“鬼魂只是顺便过来说了声嘘”。一组人100%讨厌它，一组人100%喜欢它。人们提高了嗓门。一位平时温和的编辑抗议离场。
I guess people kind of read it as like a third grade joke book joke.
我想人们把它解读为三年级笑话书里的笑话。
Editor Joe Randazzo says it was an existential fight about what kind of paper they were, that would or would not publish such a thing.
编辑乔·兰达佐说，这是一场关于他们是什么样的报纸、是否会发布这种东西的生存之战。
One member of staff may love The Onion that would never have "Ghost just dropped by to say boo," while another member of staff may love the fact that The Onion can include a joke that says "Ghost just dropped by to say boo." It's totally subjective though.
一名员工可能热爱绝不会出现“鬼魂只是顺便过来说了声嘘”的《洋葱报》，而另一名员工可能热爱《洋葱报》可以包含一个写着“鬼魂只是顺便过来说了声嘘”的笑话。这完全是主观的。
Finally, the editor in chief had to tell everybody to cut it out, and they published the joke. And this one headline did not ruin the paper. But a roomful of people who would even entertain the possibility that it might, who feel that strongly about it, that's a very tough room.
最后，主编不得不告诉所有人停止争论，他们发布了这个笑话。而这一个头条并没有毁掉报纸。但一屋子人甚至会考虑它可能毁掉报纸的可能性，对它有那么强烈的感觉，那是一个非常艰难的房间。
Act two, Bar Car Prophecy. When you're a kid, adulthood itself can seem kind of a tough room, in which you're going to have to adapt to the strange custom that is the world of adults. But for Rosie Schaap, when she was a kid, the prospect of hanging with the adults seemed exciting, an adventure.
第二幕，“酒吧车厢的预言”。当你还是个孩子时，成年本身看起来就是一个艰难的房间，你必须适应那个属于成年人的奇怪习俗。但对罗西·沙普来说，当她还是个孩子时，与成年人共处的想法似乎很令人兴奋，是一次冒险。
In 1986, when I was 15, I discovered the bar car on the Metro North New Haven line, a dingy, crowded, badly ventilated chamber, where commuters drank enough to get a decent buzz going, told dirty jokes, and chain smoked. These were my kind of people, and even though in my memory the whole place is covered in a sort of grimy yellow film, it was my kind of joint. I took the train once a week from Westport, Connecticut, to Manhattan's Grand Central Station to see my psychoanalyst. As self-absorbed as any teenager, I'd come to enjoy psychoanalysis. I'd been going since eighth grade, and the 50-minute sessions made me feel like the featured guest on a talk show. It helped that my shrink sounded a lot like Dick Cavett.
1986年，我15岁时，我发现了大都会北方新港线上的酒吧车厢，一个肮脏、拥挤、通风不良的隔间，通勤者们喝得足以产生一种不错的晕眩感，讲着下流的笑话，不停地吸着烟。这些人是我的同类，尽管在我的记忆中，整个地方都覆盖着一种灰暗的黄色薄膜，但这正是我喜欢的风格。我每周从康涅狄格州的韦斯特波特乘火车到曼哈顿中央车站去看我的精神分析师。作为一个和任何青少年一样自我沉溺的人，我开始喜欢精神分析。我从八年级就开始去了，50分钟的疗程让我感觉自己就像脱口秀的特邀嘉宾。我的心理医生听起来很像迪克·卡维特，这很有帮助。
But from the moment I first stumbled into the bar car after one of our appointments, my return trip to Westport became the best part of my Thursday visits. I liked the company of grownups, especially strangers. With them, I found it easy to feel smart and funny and interesting.
但从我第一次在疗程后跌跌撞撞地走进酒吧车厢起，我的回程变成了我周四访问中最棒的部分。我喜欢成年人的陪伴，尤其是陌生人。和他们在一起，我很容易感到聪明、风趣且有趣。
Once when I was eight and we were vacationing at the beach, my mother sent me to borrow a skillet from the neighbors, a bunch of 30-somethings in a shared rental. They were lounging on an L-shaped white couch, and seemed to get a kick out of everything I said, even the word skillet. I wasn't even sure what the word meant until a tall woman handed me a heavy pan with flared sides. I thanked her and turned to leave, but they weren't ready to let me go. They had questions. Who was I? What grade was I in? What was I into?
有一次我八岁，我们在海滩度假，妈妈派我去向邻居借一口平底锅，那是一群住在一个合租房里的30岁左右的人。他们正懒洋洋地躺在L形的白色沙发上，对我说的每一句话都感到很有趣，甚至是“平底锅”这个词。在一位高个子女士递给我一个带外翻边的沉重锅子之前，我甚至不知道这个词是什么意思。我感谢她并转身离开，但他们还没准备好放我走。他们有问题。我是谁？我上几年级？我喜欢什么？
I was astonished by their interest. I sat myself down and asked if they wanted to hear a joke. So this Jewish American princess married an Indian chief. Guess what they name their baby? I paused for effect. White fish. It's a terrible joke. I'd heard my mother tell it to one of her friends. I didn't exactly get it. But these grownups sitting there drinking wine tumbled off the big white couch laughing, and I felt like a superstar.
他们的兴趣让我感到惊讶。我坐下来问他们想不想听个笑话。所以这个犹太裔美国公主嫁给了一个印第安酋长。猜猜他们给孩子取什么名字？我为了效果暂停了一下。白鱼（White fish）。这是一个糟糕的笑话。我听我妈对她的朋友讲过。我不太明白。但这些坐着喝葡萄酒的成年人从巨大的白色沙发上滚下来笑作一团，我觉得自己像个巨星。
That's how I wanted to feel in the bar car, surrounded by its regulars, mostly men in wrinkled suits and loosened neckties. I liked listening to them. They drank beer or scotch, laughed loudly, talked fast, and always seemed happy to see each other. They were a tribe, and I wanted in. Still, I didn't dare pony up to the bar and order myself a beer. There was no way the weary Metro North crew would serve me. I needed a point of entry.
这就是我想要在酒吧车厢里感受到的，被它的常客所包围，大多是穿着皱巴巴的西装、松开领带的男人。我喜欢听他们说话。他们喝着啤酒或苏格兰威士忌，大声笑，说话很快，总是很高兴见到彼此。他们是一个部落，我想加入。不过，我不敢走到吧台给自己点杯啤酒。疲惫的大都会北方铁路工作人员绝对不会伺候我。我需要一个切入点。
I found what I was looking for the night I pulled my Tarot cards from my backpack and gave myself a reading right there in the bar car. I had been studying The Pictorial Key to the Tarot, a 1910 primer by Arthur Edward Waite, and had cultivated a look that fell somewhere between Janis Joplin and Madam Blavatsky, gauzy Indian dresses, batik caftans, chunky silver rings on my fingers. My Tarot cards smelled of patchouli and sandalwood, cigarettes and pot. I shuffled them and then began to lay them out in the Celtic cross pattern I'd learned from Waite's book.
那天晚上我从背包里拿出塔罗牌，就在酒吧车厢里给自己算了一卦，我找到了我要的东西。我一直在学习亚瑟·爱德华·韦特在1910年写的入门书《塔罗牌图解》，并精心打造了一种介于詹尼斯·乔普林和布拉瓦茨基夫人之间的造型，轻薄的印第安裙子、蜡染长衫，手指上戴着粗大的银戒指。我的塔罗牌闻起来有广藿香和檀香、香烟和大麻的味道。我洗了洗牌，然后开始按韦特书中学的凯尔特十字布局摆开。
First, the significator, the card that stood for me. Then the card that crossed me, signifying the things that blocked my path. Next, the card that crowned me, representing my ideals and aims. And so on and so on, until it laid out the 10th and final card, which would reveal the answer to my question. By then, a small crowd had gathered around me. When I finished, a woman asked if I'd give her a reading. It was the first time someone in the bar car had spoken to me without wanting to see my ticket.
首先，指引牌，代表我的牌。然后是阻碍我的牌，象征着挡在我路上的事物。接下来，加冕我的牌，代表我的理想和目标。以此类推，直到摆出第10张也是最后一张牌，它将揭示我问题的答案。到那时，一小群人聚集在我周围。当我完成时，一位女士问我是否能给她算一卦。这是酒吧车厢里的人第一次在没想看我票的情况下跟我说话。
She asked what I charged. I hadn't thought about that. I mulled it over and told her I thought it was kind of bad mojo to take money for readings, but I was cool with bartering, and I wouldn't mind a beer. She didn't ask how old I was.
她问我收费多少。我没考虑过那个。我琢磨了一下，告诉她我觉得收钱算卦有点坏了运道，但我乐于交换，不介意换杯啤酒。她没问我多大。
Her reading was good, mostly positive cards. Yes, I told her, she would thrive at her new job. She might even get a promotion soon. She smiled and discreetly got me that beer. Suddenly, it was like a divination marathon. I must have done five readings in an hour. The more I read, the more confident I grew. A routine took shape. As I laid down the cards, I'd sing Neil Young's After the Gold Rush quietly, almost under my breath.
她的牌运不错，大多是积极的牌。是的，我告诉她，她在新工作上会蒸蒸日上。她甚至可能很快得到晋升。她笑了笑，谨慎地为我弄来了那杯啤酒。突然，这就像是一场占卜马拉松。我一定在一小时内算了五卦。我算得越多，就越自信。一种常规逐渐形成。当我放下牌时，我会低声哼唱尼尔·杨的《金矿之后》，几乎是在喃喃自语。
Then, when I was done, I'd give the whole pattern an initial once over and look solemnly into the questioner's eyes. The cards are here to guide us, I'd say in a voice an octave lower than my own, but what they tell us is not carved in stone. You have the power to change any of this. And all these grownups, accountants, lawyers, executives, hung on my every word.
然后，完成后，我会对整个牌阵初步审视，郑重地看着提问者的眼睛。牌在这里指引我们，我会用比我本身低一个八度的声音说，但它们告诉我们的不是刻在石头上的。你有改变这一切的力量。而所有这些成年人，会计师、律师、高管，都对我的每一个字深信不疑。
The next week, after therapy, my fortune telling for alcohol scheme began in earnest. Again, I settled into the bar car and gave myself a reading. And again, a cluster of commuters assembled around me. I felt like I'd cracked a code. They'd sit down next to me and listen obediently. When you shuffle the cards, put your energy into them. Concentrate on your question, I instructed them. If you're doing this half-heartedly, the cards will know.
第二周，治疗结束后，我的算命换酒计划正式开始了。我又一次坐在酒吧车厢里给自己算了一卦。又一次，一群通勤者围在了我身边。我觉得我破译了某种密码。他们会坐在我旁边，顺从地听着。当你洗牌时，把你的能量投入进去。专注于你的问题，我指示他们。如果你半心半意地做这件事，牌会知道的。
This continued for weeks, and out of it I got plenty of beer, a couple of books, a pair of silver earrings. That, and the undivided attention of all these adults. I'd explain what each position in the Celtic cross meant, the significance of casting more cups than swords, more wands than pentacles. If someone's reading turned up an unusually high number of Major Arcana cards, I'd go quiet for a moment before I disclosed to him how much power that foretold, and urged him to use that power responsibly for the greater good.
这持续了几周，我得到了很多啤酒、几本书、一副银耳环。除此之外，还有所有这些成年人的全神贯注。我会解释凯尔特十字中每个位置的含义，铸造更多圣杯而不是宝剑，更多权杖而不是星币的意义。如果某人的牌出现了异常多的“大阿尔克那”牌，我会沉默片刻，然后向他透露这预示着多大的权力，并敦促他为了更大的善负责任地使用这种力量。
I never asked them their names, and I never told them mine, not my real one anyway. Yet time after time, as I laid out their futures, complete strangers would drop intimate clues about their lives, their jobs, their families. More than once, a wingtip wearing banker or salesman confided in me that he'd taken acid and sloshed around in the mud at Woodstock, and felt very connected to the energy of the universe. I'd nod and say something like, that's awesome, man. I wish I'd been there. It was as if I'd materialized before their eyes, like some ghost from their youth come back to answer questions about their future.
我从没问过他们的名字，也从没告诉过他们我的，反正不是我的真名。然而一次又一次，当我展开他们的未来时，完全陌生的人会透露关于他们生活、工作、家庭的亲密线索。不止一次，一位穿着翼纹皮鞋的银行家或推销员向我坦白说，他曾在伍德斯托克吸食过迷幻药，在泥地里打滚，感到与宇宙的能量紧密相连。我会点头说些类似“太棒了，老兄。我真希望我也在那儿。”的话。这就像我出现在他们眼前，就像某种从他们年轻时代回来的鬼魂，回来回答关于他们未来的问题。
Of course there were people in the bar car who paid me no mind, and others who made their skepticism known. But I was dismissive of the nonbelievers. They were out of touch, and that was their loss. Still, one heckler in the crowd made me nervous. I couldn't pinpoint his age, mid-30s I guessed. He was a broad shouldered, thick necked guy with a beer gut, strawberry blonde hair, and a big, ruddy face. He looked like a Kennedy, but you couldn't quite put your finger on which one. And did he have a mouth on him. The F-word used as a noun, verb, and adjective strung together in one sentence, and then the next, and the next, like artillery fire.
当然，酒吧车厢里也有人不理会我，还有人表达了他们的怀疑。但我对这些不信者嗤之以鼻。他们与世隔绝，那是他们的损失。不过，人群中有一个起哄者让我紧张。我猜不出他的年龄，大概30岁出头。他是一个肩膀宽阔、脖子粗壮、挺着啤酒肚、红头发、大红脸的家伙。他看起来像肯尼迪家族的人，但你无法确定具体是哪一个。他的嘴可真臭。F字开头的词被用作名词、动词和形容词，在同一个句子里串在一起，然后是下一句，再下一句，就像炮火一样。
The guy was always drunker and louder than anyone else. Once, he cupped his hands into a makeshift megaphone and sort of stage shouted at me something like, the '60s are over. Get a life. As much as I basked in my bar car celebrity, I dreaded seeing that guy.
这家伙总是比任何人都醉得厉害，也吵得厉害。有一次，他把双手合成一个临时的扩音器，冲我大喊大叫，大概是说“60年代结束了。去过你的生活吧。”尽管我沉浸在酒吧车厢名人的光环中，但我很怕见到那个家伙。
And then one Thursday, after I'd already served a few of my patrons, he half-staggered, half-swaggered over to me. All right, he said, this is total BS, but go ahead, do mine. He plunked himself down across from me, his knees a little too close. I wanted to tell him to go away. I wanted to tell him that his unwillingness to believe would insult the spirits and make them uncooperative, but I worried he'd call me a fraud.
然后一个周四，在我已经为几个顾客服务后，他半摇晃、半大摇大摆地朝我走来。好了，他说，这全是狗屎，但随便吧，给我算算。他一屁股坐在我对面，膝盖离我太近了。我想让他走开。我想告诉他，他不情愿的相信会侮辱神灵，使它们不配合，但我担心他会叫我骗子。
I played it cool and started my spiel. Shuffle, focus, give the cards your energy. He rolled his eyes but played along. He cut the cards once and handed me the deck. I laid them out. First I set down his significator, the 10 of swords, possibly the worst card of all, with a solitary, prostrate figure under a black sky, pierced in the back by all 10 swords. It represents, in Waite's words, pain, affliction, sadness.
我冷静下来，开始我的那套词。洗牌，集中注意力，把你的能量交给牌。他翻了个白眼，但还是照做了。他切了一次牌，把牌组递给我。我摆开了它们。首先我放下了他的指引牌，宝剑十，可能所有牌中最糟糕的一张，一个孤独的、面朝下趴在黑夜下的人，背上插着所有10把剑。它代表，用韦特的话说，痛苦、折磨、悲伤。
The rest of the cards weren't much better. He pulled the tower, a card signaling corruption, destruction, and the presence of evil. He got the death card too. And as much as I disliked the guy, I really didn't like what I saw on those cards, not for anyone, not even for him.
其余的牌也好不到哪去。他抽到了塔，一张预示腐败、毁灭和邪恶存在的牌。他还抽到了死神牌。尽管我很不喜欢这家伙，但我真的很不喜欢我在牌上看到的东西，对任何人都不喜欢，对他更不喜欢。
I kept quiet for long minute while I tried to figure out how to spin this, but there was nothing good I could say. Maintaining eye contact is key to being a good mystic, but I couldn't even meet his gaze. Well, what's it say? he finally asked. I took a deep breath. None of this is carved in stone or written in blood. He cut me off, well, what? So I told him what I saw, and as I interpreted one dismal symbol after another, the guy leaned in closer, put his elbows on the table, buried his head in his hands, and started to cry.
我沉默了很久，试着想出如何美化这一点，但什么好话也说不出来。保持眼神交流是做一个好神秘主义者的关键，但我甚至不敢迎上他的目光。好吧，上面说了什么？他终于问了。我深吸了一口气。这一切都不是刻在石头上或写在血里的。他打断我，好吧，什么？所以我告诉了他我看到的，当我解释一个又一个凄凉的符号时，这家伙倾过身子，把手肘放在桌子上，把头埋在手里，开始哭泣。
He told me that his marriage was falling apart. That he constantly worried about his health. That he was too young for heart problems, but he had them. That he felt as though his life had added up to zero. He asked, will I ever be happy? The cards, I answered bluntly, said no. But, I told him, just like I told everyone else, you have the power to change that. He shook his head and glared at me with red, swollen eyes that said he did not. Maybe he didn't. Maybe no one had the power. Maybe the days that lie ahead of us are set in stone and that was that, and maybe I'd been the cynic.
他告诉我他的婚姻正在分崩离析。他总是担心自己的健康。他心脏问题太年轻了，但他确实有。他觉得他的一生加起来等于零。他问，我会幸福吗？牌，我直截了当地回答，说不会。但是，我告诉他，就像我告诉其他人一样，你有改变这一点的力量。他摇了摇头，用红肿的眼睛瞪着我，眼神说着他没有。也许他没有。也许没人有那样的力量。也许我们面前的日子是注定的，就是那样，也许我一直是个愤世嫉俗者。
Something I had believed in had become a gambit for attention. I hadn't thought it through, and maybe I'd even hurt people. In the background, other passengers were caught up in conversation, laughing and drinking and carrying on. I could think of nothing more to say to the guy, nothing reassuring. I felt small and foolish, and when the guy finally got off the train a couple of stops before mine, I was relieved.
我所相信的东西已经变成了一种博取关注的手段。我没有深思熟虑，也许我甚至伤害了人。在背景中，其他乘客沉浸在谈话中，笑着、喝着、闹着。我再也想不出对这家伙能说什么，没有什么能让他安心的话。我觉得自己渺小而愚蠢，当那家伙终于在离我两站的地方下火车时，我感到如释重负。
I sat awake in my bed that night and thought about him. I imagined him going home to a white clapboard colonial, to an unhappy wife pretending to be asleep. I imagined him returning the next day to a job he hated, and getting wasted again that afternoon. But of course, at 15, I couldn't imagine what it was like to be him, to live his life, and I realized I didn't want to be able to. Reading Tarot cards in the bar car had been fun until it got serious. Adults had problems I could not begin to fathom, and they had things to say I wasn't ready to hear.
那天晚上我躺在床上清醒着，想着他。我想象着他回到一栋白色的殖民地风格房子里，回到一个假装睡着的、不幸福的妻子身边。我想象他第二天回到一份他讨厌的工作中，那天下午又喝得烂醉。但当然，在15岁时，我无法想象成为他是什么感觉，无法过他的生活，我意识到我不想有那样的能力。在酒吧车厢里读塔罗牌很有趣，直到它变得严肃。成年人有我无法想象的问题，他们有我没准备好听到的话要说。
I didn't go back to the bar car. I missed the grownups, I missed their attention, but I was not one of them. I didn't belong there. Although I could feel adulthood encroaching, real adulthood, which now seemed less about drinking and smoking and freedom, and more about loss, and fear, and the sense that death itself lay waiting somewhere just ahead.
我没有再回酒吧车厢。我想念那些成年人，想念他们的关注，但我不是他们中的一员。我不属于那里。虽然我能感觉到成年正在逼近，真正的成年，现在看起来不再是关于喝酒、抽烟和自由，而是关于损失、恐惧，以及那种死亡本身就潜伏在前方某个地方的感觉。
Rosie Schaap. This story comes from a book of essays that she's writing about drinking called Drinking With Men . She's looking for a publisher.
罗西·沙普。这个故事来自她正在写的一本关于饮酒的文章集《与男人饮酒》。她正在寻找出版商。
Coming up, if Jerry Seinfeld became a Mormon tomorrow, the most likely way that it would happen would be because of two guys that we are going to introduce you to. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
即将到来，如果杰瑞·宋飞明天成为摩门教徒，最可能发生的方式将是因为我们要介绍给你的两个人。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme, and-- Hello? Hello? [TAPS MICROPHONE] Hello? Anybody out there? OK, if you're out there, make a noise. Tough room. That's our theme. Very clever how we do this here on the public radio, huh? We've arrived at act three of our show. Act three, Mission Impossible.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来各种各样的故事——喂？喂？[敲麦克风] 喂？有人在那儿吗？好的，如果你在那儿，发出点声音。艰难的房间。这是我们的主题。我们在这里做公共广播的方式很聪明，对吧？我们已经来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“不可能的任务”。
In the Bible, God is constantly sending his prophets into situations where nobody wants to hear what they have to say. And after high school, young Mormon men are basically supposed to do the same thing. They are encouraged to go on a two year mission to spread the gospel. They pay their own way. Jane Feltes has followed two of these guys out to convert people in a place that we usually don't think of as a bastion of Mormonism, or particularly friendly to missionaries: the Upper West Side of Manhattan.
在圣经中，上帝不断派遣先知进入没人想听他们说话的境地。高中毕业后，年轻的摩门教男子基本上也要做同样的事情。他们被鼓励去进行为期两年的传教活动，传播福音。他们自费前往。简·费尔特斯跟踪了这两个人，去一个我们通常不认为摩门教堡垒，或者对传教士特别友好的地方转化人们：曼哈顿的上西区。
Elder [? Longing-- ?] elder doesn't mean older, it's just a title given to missionaries-- is 20, an army brat most recently from Utah. Elder [? Meller ?] is from Utah too, and he's 21. They're both in the second year of their mission, so they kind of have it down.
长老[？Longing--？]长老并不意味着年纪大，这只是给传教士的一个头衔——20岁，一个军人家庭出身，最近来自犹他州。长老[？Meller？]也是来自犹他州，21岁。他们都处于传教的第二年，所以他们对此相当熟练。
How are doing today sir? Have you ever had the chance to read the Book of Mormon? No chance? All right, do you know anyone in the area we can share our message about Christ with?
您好，先生，今天怎么样？你有机会读过摩门经吗？没机会？好的，你知道附近有什么人我们可以分享我们关于基督的信息吗？
The guy literally tells him, get lost.
那家伙直接告诉他，滚开。
You don't know anybody in the area we can do some service for? All right, you have a great day, sir.
你不知道附近有什么人我们可以提供一些服务吗？好的，祝你今天过得愉快，先生。
Today they're stopping people outside the American Museum of Natural History, but they work all over New York and its suburbs. And the toughest thing about being a missionary in New York isn't what you might think, that it's too secular, too Jewish, or too unfriendly or too cool for school, especially Sunday school. No, the problem is competition. In New York, there are so many distractions on the street, people trying to hand you fliers or get you into their hair salon or comedy show. And if you're saying no to someone who asks, do you have one minute to save the environment, you're not going to say yes to these guys.
今天他们在自然历史博物馆外拦人，但他们在纽约及其郊区到处工作。在纽约当传教士最难的事情不是你可能想到的那种，即它太世俗、太犹太化，或者太不友好，或者对学校太酷，尤其是主日学。不，问题在于竞争。在纽约，街头有太多的干扰，人们试图把传单塞给你，或者把你拉进他们的美发沙龙或喜剧表演中。如果你拒绝了一个问你“你有一分钟来拯救环境吗”的人，你也不会对这些人说是的。
Everyone's walking on the street, and everybody's walking about the same pace, and anything that will disrupt the flow will cause them to be angry, just because they're already in the mindset that they're going somewhere. Anything that stops them is going to make them angry. And usually we're the ones that stop them. We're usually that disruption.
每个人都在街上走，大家都以同样的速度走，任何扰乱流动的事情都会引起他们的愤怒，仅仅是因为他们已经有了去某处的心理预设。任何阻碍他们的东西都会让他们生气。而通常我们就是那个阻碍他们的人。我们通常就是那种干扰。
Both guys are living off their savings while they're here. Elder [? Longing ?] lives in Chinatown with three other missionaries in a two bedroom apartment. Elder [? Meller's ?] two bedroom in Harlem houses six missionaries. And for 12 hours every day, from 9:00 AM to 9:00 PM, most of their interactions are less than 30 seconds, if you can even call them interactions.
两个人都靠在这里时的存款生活。长老[？Longing？]和另外三个传教士住在唐人街的一套两居室公寓里。长老[？Meller？]在哈莱姆的两居室里住了六个传教士。每天12小时，从上午9点到晚上9点，他们大部分的互动都在30秒以内，如果这甚至能称之为互动的话。
Hey sister.
嘿，姐妹。
Elder [? Meller ?] calls out to a cute woman in her late 20s.
长老[？Meller？]向一个20多岁可爱的女士大喊。
Have you ever seen this picture before?
你看过这张照片吗？
I'm sorry?
对不起？
He shows her a picture of Jesus baptizing Peter on the cover of his Book of Mormon.
他给她看一张耶稣在摩门经封面上给彼得施洗的照片。
Have you ever seen this picture before?
你看过这张照片吗？
Yes, I have.
看过。
That's good. We want to invite you to be baptized by that same authority that he's given.
那很好。我们想邀请你接受他所给予的同样权威的洗礼。
I'm Christian. I don't know if that matters.
我是基督徒。我不知道那有没有关系。
Yeah, we are too.
是的，我们也是。
But I'm not Mormon. Thank you though.
但我不是摩门教徒。谢谢你。
But I'm not Mormon, she says, thank you though.
但我不是摩门教徒，她说，谢谢你。
I wouldn't talk to you if you were Mormon, right? Where are you from?
如果你是摩门教徒我就不会和你说话了，对吧？你来自哪儿？
She's gone within seven seconds. Par for the course, says Elder [? Longing. ?]
她在七秒内就走了。长老[？Longing？]说，这是常态。
I don't know if you saw, but when people say no, and we're still trying to talk to them, we're just trying different things. No, I don't want that. Do you know anyone who does want it? No, I don't know. Well, do you know anyone who wants to come to church? No, I don't know anybody. Well, do you want to come to church?
不知道你有没有看到，但当人们说不，而我们仍在试图和他们说话时，我们只是在尝试不同的东西。不，我不想要那个。你知道有人想要吗？不，我不知道。好吧，你知道有人想来教堂吗？不，我不认识任何人。好吧，你想来教堂吗？
And then they walk away and you feel what?
然后他们走开了，你感觉怎么样？
And I feel like that guy really does not want to go to church. Sometimes I get defensive, like under my breath, I'll mutter something.
我觉得那家伙真的不想去教堂。有时我会感到防御，比如在嘴里咕哝一些话。
Elder [? Longing, ?] do you ever get my baby's sleeping, I have to go watch it.
长老[？Longing？]，你有没有遇到过“我宝宝在睡觉，我得去照顾它”的情况？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
I hate that. It's like, it's sleeping, you don't need to watch it.
我讨厌那个。就像，它在睡觉，你不需要照顾它。
Yeah, excuses.
是的，借口。
Hey brother, how are you feeling today? How are you doing today, brother? Hey sisters, can we invite you guys to get your Mormon on by coming--
嘿，兄弟，今天感觉如何？今天怎么样，兄弟？嘿，姐妹们，我们能邀请你们加入摩门教，通过来到——
Calling everybody brother and sister was not working at all for them.
称呼每个人为兄弟姐妹对他们根本没有作用。
Have a good one.
祝你过得好。
I figured it had to be a Mormon thing. Turns out it's not.
我想这肯定是摩门教的习俗。结果发现不是。
I picked that up in the Bronx. You'd say hey, what's up brother? And so usually in the Bronx, they're like, hey, what's up? And they'll say it back.
我在布朗克斯学到的。你会说嘿，怎么了兄弟？所以通常在布朗克斯，他们会说，嘿，怎么了？他们会回敬你。
This definitely ain't the Bronx though. Right across the street lives Jerry Seinfeld, Glenn Close, John McEnroe, and Helen Gurley Brown, which makes it the toughest kind of neighborhood for missionaries. In the Bronx, people will talk to them, let them visit their homes. But the wealthier the area, they say, like here on Central Park West, it's a much harder sell.
但这绝对不是布朗克斯。街对面住着杰瑞·宋飞、格伦·克洛斯、约翰·麦肯罗和海伦·格利·布朗，这使它成为对传教士来说最艰难的社区。在布朗克斯，人们会和他们说话，让他们去家里。但他们说，越富裕的地区，比如在这里的中央公园西，推销起来就越难。
Spreading the word about Mormonism is a numbers game, and to talk to the greatest number of people in a day in New York City, the guys have each learned how to strike up a conversation in at least five different languages. Elder [? Longing ?] approaches a man sitting on the steps.
传播摩门教信息是一场数字游戏，为了在纽约市一天中能与最多的人交谈，他们每个人都学会了至少用五种不同的语言开启对话。长老[？Longing？]接近一个坐在台阶上的男人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Elder [? Meller ?] hears a woman speaking French to her child.
长老[？Meller？]听到一个女人对着她的孩子说法语。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[说法语]
And Elder [? Longing, ?] he even knows some sign language.
而且长老[？Longing？]，他甚至知道一些手语。
My sign language is improving.
我的手语在进步。
Over the course of the afternoon, approaching every person who walks by, they get a couple dozen cards with the church's address into people's hands. They say on average they manage to get about three or four new people to come to church each week, which seems amazingly low, given that it's two of them working basically every waking minute.
整个下午，接近每个经过的人，他们能将几十张写有教堂地址的卡片分发到人们手中。他们说平均每周能争取到三四个新面孔来教堂，鉴于他们两个几乎每时每刻都在工作，这看起来低得惊人。
Are these skills that you're learning out here these few years, are they things you think you're going to take into your career?
这些你在外面几年学到的技能，是你认为你会带入职业生涯的东西吗？
Yes. Most definitely.
是的。非常肯定。
Most definitely.
非常肯定。
What are you going to do?
你打算做什么？
I thought about it. I was like, I bet selling life insurance is way easier than this. Because I've met people who do sell life insurance, and they're like--
我想过。我想，我打赌卖人寿保险比这容易多了。因为我见过卖人寿保险的人，他们像——
They're happy people.
他们是幸福的人。
They're very successful. I wonder what I could do if I did that. Or like those guys who sell scissors, go door to door, like Cutco, they sell scissors. I'm like, I'm sure I could sell some scissors. Like sometimes I think, I think I could sell scissors better than that guy, because you know how to deal with people turning you down. Like even if you get turned down over and over again, it's finding that little thing that keeps you going, that little thing that keeps you talking to people.
他们非常成功。我想知道如果我做那个我能做什么。或者像那些挨家挨户卖剪刀的人，像Cutco，他们卖剪刀。我想，我肯定能卖掉一些剪刀。就像有时我觉得，我觉得我能比那个家伙卖得更好，因为你知道如何应对人们的拒绝。即使你一次又一次地被拒绝，也要找到让你坚持下去的那一点点东西，那让你保持和人交谈的那一点点东西。
But in this, that little thing that keeps you going is like eternal life. With scissors, I don't know if--
但在这些事情中，让你坚持下去的那一点点东西就像永生。如果是剪刀，我不知道如果——
I don't know, a paycheck. I don't know.
我不知道，一份工资。我不知道。
While I'm with them, their longest conversations are with guys who seem down on their luck. One guy might have been drunk, and another guy who, if he wasn't homeless, was probably often mistaken for homeless. And they spend even more time with people they have no hope of baptizing, like this guy.
当我和他们在一起时，他们最长的对话是和那些运气不好的家伙进行的。一个人可能是喝醉了，另一个如果不是无家可归，也经常被误认为是无家可归者。他们花更多时间在他们毫无希望转化的人身上，比如这家伙。
Here you go, last one. I don't like the way they translated it, but OK. Read this.
给你，最后一个。我不喜欢他们翻译它的方式，但没关系。读这个。
Elder [? Meller is ?] standing talking to a middle aged orthodox Jewish man in a navy trench coat and hat. The two men get into a long, in-depth discussion about religion, specifically whether, as the Mormons believe, a prophet walked the Earth in America in the 1800s.
长老[？Meller？]站着和一个穿着海军蓝风衣和戴着帽子的中年正统犹太人交谈。两人就宗教问题进行了深入的讨论，特别是摩门教徒所相信的那个问题，即一位先知是否在1800年代在美国大地上行走。
What about Jeremiah and things like that?
耶利米和其他人怎么样？
In dreams, they had dreams. God did not speak to them.
在梦里，他们有梦。上帝没有对他们说话。
All right. Our message is that God has a prophet on the Earth again.
好的。我们的信息是上帝再次在地球上有了一位先知。
There are many prophets.
有很多先知。
This is true, but there are those ordained, like Moses.
这是事实，但有那些被任命的，像摩西。
It's like watching a couple football fans talk about the Super Bowl, even though they were rooting for different teams. They know they'll never convince the other that their team is better, but they're really enjoying the back and forth. They seemed relieved to have found someone who relates to the world the way they do.
这就像看着一对足球迷谈论超级碗，尽管他们支持不同的球队。他们知道他们永远不会说服对方他们的球队更好，但他们真的很享受这种来回交谈。他们似乎为找到了一个以同样方式看待世界的人而感到宽慰。
God bless you.
上帝保佑你。
You too brother. Have a good one.
也保佑你，兄弟。祝你过得好。
I think some of my favorite people I like talking to, I like talking to Jews, and I like talking to Muslims. Muslims are really cool, just because I find that they're more devout. It's easier for me to talk to them because they are very faithful people.
我想我最喜欢交谈的一些人，我喜欢和犹太人交谈，我也喜欢和穆斯林交谈。穆斯林真的很酷，因为我发现他们更虔诚。对我来说和他们交谈更容易，因为他们是非常忠实的人。
You guys have that in common.
你们有共同点。
That's true. But more like going along with the Jews and Muslims and stuff is they understand the idea of a covenant, a two way agreement. So they're more devout with it.
这是真的。但和犹太人和穆斯林相处更多的是因为他们理解契约的概念，一种双向协议。所以他们对此更虔诚。
At 6:00 PM, it's dark and so cold nobody's on the street anymore. So the guys head off on a home visit, to meet with a new potential convert. They have three hours of work ahead of them today, and roughly a combined 3,240 hours to go.
下午6点，天黑了，非常冷，街上已经没人了。所以他们前往进行家访，去见一位潜在的新信徒。他们今天还有三小时的工作要做，加起来总共还有大约3240小时。
Jane Feltes is one of the producers of our show.
简·费尔特斯是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act four, Tough Newsroom. These days, Malcolm Gladwell is very good at what he does. He's a reporter. He writes for the New Yorker magazine. He's had a number of iconic bestselling books, including The Tipping Point and Blink . But it was not always this way. No, no, no. Once upon a time, the world of journalism was a totally forbidden and alien place to him. And he talked about this onstage at The Moth in New York City.
第四幕，“艰难的新闻编辑室”。这些天，马尔科姆·格拉德威尔在做的事情上非常出色。他是一名记者。他为《纽约客》杂志撰稿。他有许多标志性的畅销书，包括《引爆点》和《眨眼》。但情况并不总是这样。不，不，不。曾几何时，新闻界对他来说是一个完全被禁止和陌生的领域。他在纽约市的“飞蛾”舞台上谈论了这一点。
My first job, my first real job, was at the Washington Post , and I still don't know really know how I got hired, because I didn't have any newspaper experience. I hadn't even worked for my high school newspaper. But they put me on the business desk, which is where you put people at the Washington Post who don't know anything about journalism. And I just sat there for the first six weeks, and I didn't do a thing.
我的第一份工作，我的第一份真正的工作，是在《华盛顿邮报》，我到现在还不知道自己是怎么被录用的，因为我没有任何报纸经验。我甚至没在高中校报工作过。但他们把我放在了商业版块，那是《华盛顿邮报》给那些对新闻一无所知的人准备的地方。我在那儿坐了前六周，什么都没做。
And people were looking at me and wondering about me, and finally the business editor took pity on me, and he gave me an earnings story to do. It was about a local company named Maryland Biosciences, and I just had to write up their earnings. And so I wrote it up, like three paragraphs long, it took me like five hours, and that was my first story in the Washington Post .
人们看着我，怀疑我，最后商业编辑对我产生怜悯，他给了我一篇财报故事。那是关于一家名为马里兰生物科学的当地公司，我只需要写他们的财报。所以我就写了，大概三段话，花了我五个小时，那就是我在《华盛顿邮报》的第一篇报道。
But unfortunately, I wrote that the Maryland Biosciences had lost $5 million in the previous quarter, and they in fact had made $5 million in the previous quarter. And on the morning the story ran, the stock dropped 10 points. And the CEO called Ben Bradlee on the phone and just chewed him out. And I got in all kinds of trouble, and I was put on probation. And if I had doubts about journalism before, they were redoubled now. And I was wondering, what am I doing? I can't even read a balance sheet properly. And I really was despairing, and I was turning over this story again and again. How did I do it? Where did I go wrong?
但不幸的是，我写道马里兰生物科学在上一季度亏损了500万美元，而他们实际上盈利了500万美元。报道刊登那天早上，股价下跌了10个点。首席执行官打电话给本·布拉德利，把他痛骂了一顿。我惹了各种麻烦，并被置于试用期。如果我之前对新闻业有疑问，现在更是加倍了。我想，我在干什么？我甚至不能正确阅读资产负债表。我真的很绝望，我一遍又一遍地翻看这个故事。我是怎么做的？我在哪里出了错？
And then I had a kind of epiphany, which I really credit for why I stayed in journalism, and didn't go selling real estate, or whatever the other things I was thinking of doing in that moment. I realized first of all that I had made up this story, but I'd gotten into the paper, and no one had stopped me. And secondly, I'd moved the stock 10 points. And it was a kind of Jayson Blair moment. And all of a sudden, there's a little glimmer, and I can begin to see that there's some hope in this profession. This thing that didn't make sense to me is now kind of making sense.
然后我产生了一种顿悟，我真正归功于这一点，是我留在新闻界，没有去卖房地产，或者在那一刻我想做的其他事情。我意识到首先我编造了这个故事，但它登上了报纸，没有人阻止我。其次，我让股价移动了10个点。那是一种杰森·布莱尔时刻。突然间，有一点微光，我开始看到这个职业还有希望。这件对我来说毫无意义的事情现在变得有意义了。
I get moved to the health desk and science desk, which is where they put you at the Washington Post if you know even less than the people in the business. And one of the first stories I did was a story about the AIDS conference, which was a big deal back then. There were three cities being considered for the next conference, Rome, Vancouver, and Amsterdam. And it's a big deal for a reporter, because you got to go to one of these cities, and it was a week's paid vacation.
我被调到了健康版和科学版，那是《华盛顿邮报》如果你知道的比商业版的人更少时会把你放到的地方。我做的第一批报道之一是关于艾滋病会议的故事，那在当时是一件大事。有三个城市在考虑主办下一次会议，罗马、温哥华和阿姆斯特丹。这对记者来说是一件大事，因为你可以去其中一个城市，这是一周的带薪假期。
But my problem with Rome, Amsterdam, and Vancouver, they're very nice cities, but I'd been to all of them. And I really in my heart of hearts wanted to go to Australia. And so I'm writing up the story, and I thought, would anyone mind? So I just said, NIH officials said they were considering Rome, Vancouver, Amsterdam, and Sydney. And the next morning, I see that the wires have picked up the story, and they've called the Sydney Tourist Bureau, and they said are you at all interested in hosting the AIDS convention? And they said, well of course. And then the Miami Herald picked up the story, and they called the NIH, and they said, Sydney says they're really interested in hosting.
但关于罗马、阿姆斯特丹和温哥华的问题，它们是非常好的城市，但我都去过。我内心深处真的很想去澳大利亚。所以我在写故事时，我想，有人介意吗？所以我只是说，NIH官员说他们正在考虑罗马、温哥华、阿姆斯特丹和悉尼。第二天早上，我看到通讯社采用了这个故事，他们打了电话给悉尼旅游局，他们说你们有兴趣主办艾滋病大会吗？他们说，那当然了。然后《迈阿密先驱报》采用了这个故事，他们打了电话给NIH，他们说，悉尼说他们非常有兴趣主办。
And the guys at NIH, what do they know? They're like, that's fantastic. Yes, we are considering-- I can't tell you how exhilarated this makes me feel. And I have a sense of real power for the first time.
而NIH的那些家伙，他们知道什么？他们说，那太棒了。是的，我们正在考虑——我无法告诉你这让我感到多么振奋。我第一次有了真正的权力感。
Right around that time, a new guy joined the science desk, a guy named Billy Booth, and Billy didn't come from newspapers either. And I could tell that he was as shell shocked as I had been. So I went to him and I said, Billy, I know how you feel. I've been there. But there's a secret to this business. It's not what you think, it's actually quite-- and one of the things we get to do is that we had to read all of these medical journals every week. And every week there would be some new paper describing some incredibly obscure disease that scientists had made some advance against.
就在那时，科学版来了一个新员工，一个名叫比利·布斯的家伙，比利也不是来自报社。我看得出他和我一样受到了震撼。所以我去找他，我说，比利，我知道你的感受。我经历过。但这个行业有个秘密。它不是你想象的那样，实际上相当——我们可以做的事情之一就是我们要每周阅读所有这些医学期刊。每周都会有某种描述科学家取得某种进展的极其晦涩的疾病的新论文。
And I said to Billy, we can write about these diseases, but we don't have to tell anyone that they're obscure. And so we started something called disease of the week. We would write about these diseases, and we would find some lab technician, and we would quote them as saying this is the greatest thing that ever happened. Of course, it was for the lab technician. We'd put in like the 19th paragraph that this a disease that only afflicted one in every 400 million people.
我对比利说，我们可以写这些疾病，但我们不必告诉任何人它们是晦涩的。所以我们开始了所谓的“本周疾病”。我们会写这些疾病，我们会找某个实验室技术员，我们会引用他们的话说这是有史以来最伟大的事情。当然，那是对实验室技术员而言。我们在第19段写道这是一种每4亿人中仅有一人患上的疾病。
And every week we did another disease, and every week we got a little bolder. And the stories got just a little bit more outrageous, and they started running not on a 16, or not on 15, and then 13, and then 2, and then on the front page. And we started to have a certain kind of swagger. We felt like drunk with power. But it wasn't enough. And we began to think, you know what? It's not enough just to cure diseases. We'd like to effect to change the very language of American journalism. And that's when the contest was born.
每周我们都做另一种疾病，每周我们都变得更大胆一点。故事变得越来越离谱，它们开始不再运行在第16版，不再是第15，然后第13，第2，然后到了头条。我们开始有了一种特定的姿态。我们感觉像被权力灌醉了。但这还不够。我们开始想，你知道吗？光治愈疾病是不够的。我们想改变美国新闻业本身的语言。那时候，竞赛诞生了。
Now, I don't remember whose idea the contest was, whether it was me or Billy, but we were just so inseparable in those days, it was probably a combination. But what we decided was to introduce the phrase "raises new and troubling questions" to American journalism. And the contest was that we were going to give ourselves a month, and the person who got that phrase into the newspaper the most times over the course of the month would win.
现在，我不记得这是谁的主意，是我还是比利，但在那些日子里我们形影不离，很可能是一个组合。但我们决定引入“引发新的和令人不安的问题”这个短语到美国新闻业。竞赛是我们给自己一个月的时间，在一个月内把那个短语放进报纸次数最多的人将获胜。
And so I struck first. It was a story on Medicare spending. Medicare had gone up 12% the previous year, which I said raises new and troubling questions about the status of the American health care establishment. Billy comes back the next day, he'd got a piece from one of the physics journals about this sub-atomic particle called the Higgs boson, which was very big in the '90s. And he said that this recent work on Higgs boson raises new and troubling questions about our understanding of dark matter. And so we're tied.
所以我先出手了。那是一个关于医疗保险开支的故事。医疗保险在过去一年上涨了12%，我说这“引发了关于美国医疗保健机构地位的新的和令人不安的问题”。比利第二天回击，他从物理学期刊之一得到了一篇关于这种名为希格斯玻色子的亚原子粒子的文章，这在90年代非常大。他说，这项关于希格斯玻色子的最新工作“引发了关于我们对暗物质理解的新的和令人不安的问题”。于是我们平手了。
Two days later, I come back. Piece on FDA cutbacks, raises new and troubling questions about the safety of the nation's drug supply. Billy does a piece, a wonderful profile of this botanist, in which he said that her most recent work raises new and troubling questions about our understanding of non-flowering perennials. It's back and forth. It's a horse race. And we get consumed by this. And we're showing up 8:00 in the morning to check the wires, looking for things that are conceivably both new and troubling.
两天后，我回击。关于FDA裁员的报道，“引发了关于国家药品供应安全新的和令人不安的问题”。比利做了一篇报道，一篇关于这位植物学家的精彩侧写，他在其中说她最近的工作“引发了关于我们对非开花多年生植物理解的新的和令人不安的问题”。来来回回。这是一场拉锯战。我们沉迷于此。我们早上8点就去查看通讯社，寻找可能既是新的又是令人不安的事情。
One day left in the contest, we've done 30 days, I'm ahead 10-9, and I'm convinced I got it in the bag. Right at the end of the afternoon, Billy pulls something off the wires about declining test scores, writes a little thing, it's this long, about how this raises new and troubling questions about the intellectual fitness of American schoolchildren. Gets it in the paper, and not only that, the copy desk, when they're making up the headline for the story, the headline is, "Report raises new and troubling questions." It's a twofer. He goes ahead of me 11-10, I feel like I've been kicked in the stomach. It's devastating.
竞赛最后一天，我们做了30天，我以10比9领先，我确信我稳赢了。就在下午结束时，比利从通讯社拿到了关于考试分数下降的消息，写了一篇小东西，关于这如何“引发了关于美国学童智力健康的新的和令人不安的问题”。它登上了报纸，不仅如此，编辑部在为故事构思标题时，标题就是，“报告引发了新的和令人不安的问题”。这是双赢。他以11比10领先我，我觉得我被踢了胃部。这太毁灭性了。
And I go to Billy and I say, we're not done. We need to have a championship round. And by the way, raises new and troubling questions was too easy, because everything raises new and troubling questions. So we need to have a much tougher standard this time. I said, what are you thinking? He said, I think we should use the word perverse. And I said, no way. I think we should use the phrase often baffling. So we argue back and forth, and finally we compromise, and we go with perverse and often baffling.
我去对比利说，我们还没完。我们需要进行一场冠军赛。顺便说一下，“引发新的和令人不安的问题”太简单了，因为每件事都引发新的和令人不安的问题。所以这次我们需要一个更严厉的标准。我说，你在想什么？他说，我觉得我们应该使用“反常的”这个词。我说，没门。我觉得我们应该使用“常常令人困惑的”这个短语。所以我们争论来争论去，最后我们妥协了，我们选择了“反常的和常常令人困惑的”。
Now, I don't need to tell you how hard it is to get the phrase perverse and often baffling into a newspaper. You've got to find something that is-- perverse isn't good enough. Baffling isn't good enough. Perverse and baffling isn't good enough. It must be perverse and often baffling. It must oscillate between the state of bafflement and transparency, while simultaneously remaining perverse.
现在，我不需要告诉你把“反常的和常常令人困惑的”这个短语放进报纸有多难。你必须找到某种东西是——反常的不够好。令人困惑的不够好。反常的和令人困惑的不够好。它必须是反常的和常常令人困惑的。它必须在困惑状态和透明度之间摇摆，同时保持反常。
We killed ourselves on that one. Literally, it was an obsession. We would come in and we would just sweat it out, and we would try and try. Billy did a piece on mollusks once, in which he tried to claim that mollusks represented a perverse and often baffling something. And the copy desk took out often, arguing, I think correctly, that mollusks were either baffling or they weren't. Mollusks did not oscillate.
我们在那个上面杀死了自己。实际上，那是一种痴迷。我们会进去，我们会流汗，我们会不断尝试。比利有一次做了一篇关于软体动物的文章，在其中他试图声称软体动物代表了一种反常的和常常令人困惑的东西。编辑部删去了“常常”，争论说，我认为正确地，软体动物要么是令人困惑的，要么不是。软体动物不会摇摆。
I came back with a piece on the anthropology of women's breasts. I claimed that they represented a perverse and often baffling development in anthropology, and my editor took out perverse and said, this is a family newspaper. You can't call women's breasts perverse. And I went to the mat on that one. Finally, the story was killed. It was ugly. Anyway, we're really broken up about this. We can't get this damn phrase in the paper, and we're going out drinking at night. And a lot of my old doubts about journalism are starting to come back. And I'm saying, do I really want to be part of a profession that has no room for the perverse and the often baffling?
我带着一篇关于女性乳房人类学的文章回来。我声称它们代表了一种人类学中反常的和常常令人困惑的发展，我的编辑删去了“反常的”，说，这是一份家庭报纸。你不能称女性乳房为反常的。我为此抗争到底。最后，故事被毙了。这太难看了。无论如何，我们对此真的很崩溃。我们无法把这该死的短语放进报纸，我们晚上出去喝酒。我对新闻业的许多旧怀疑开始回归。我在说，我真的想成为一个没有反常和常常令人困惑空间职业的一部分吗？
And then one day, I'm having this conversation with a gastroentrologist. And he tells me that, did I know that there were more gastroentrologists per capita in Washington DC than any other city in the country? And I said, I did not know that. But then I said, I thought that doctor's fees were higher in Washington DC than anywhere else in the country? And he goes, yeah. Light bulb goes on above my head, because the law of supply and demand says, the greater the supply, the lower the price should be. But here we have a case where we've got a very large supply of gastroentrologists, but the price of gastroentrologists is going up. That is a perverse phenomenon, and until I explain it to you, it's baffling.
然后有一天，我和一位胃肠科医生交谈。他告诉我，你知道华盛顿特区的人均胃肠科医生比该国任何其他城市都多吗？我说，我不知道。但我说，我认为华盛顿特区的医生费用比该国任何地方都高吗？他说，是的。我头上亮起了灯泡，因为供求规律说，供应越大，价格应该越低。但这里我们有一个案例，我们有大量的胃肠科医生，但他们的费用却在上涨。那是一个反常的现象，在我向你解释之前，它是令人困惑的。
I raced back to the office, whipping into my desk, make a couple of phone calls, and I bang it out. And you can look it up, right on the front page, September 21, 1992, "Washington DC has more gastroentrologists per capita than any other city in the country. But in a reflection of the perverse and often baffling economics of the health care profession, it simultaneously has the highest doctor's fees in the country."
我冲回办公室，猛地冲向桌子，打了几通电话，我写完了。你可以查一下，就在头条，1992年9月21日，“华盛顿特区的人均胃肠科医生比该国任何其他城市都多。但在医疗保健行业反常的和常常令人困惑的经济学的反映下，它同时也拥有该国最高的医生费用。”
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Billy is devastated. I am triumphant. All those doubts about journalism melt away, and I say, this thing called newspaper writing, I can do it. One week passes, I get a letter in the mail. Dear sir, with respect to your story on the gastroentrologists of the Washington DC region, the economics of the health care profession are neither perverse nor baffling.
比利很崩溃。我是胜利者。所有关于新闻业的怀疑都融化了，我说，这种叫报纸写作的东西，我能做到。一周过去，我收到了邮寄的一封信。先生，关于您关于华盛顿特区地区胃肠科医生的报道，医疗保健行业的经济学既不反常也不令人困惑。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Malcolm Gladwell, on stage at the Moth, where people come to tell both true stories and occasional tall tales. This story appears in one of the Moth's greatest hits collections. Their website, where they have all kinds of free stories to listen to, is themoth.org. By the way, if there's any ambiguity in here at all, young journalists please note, putting false information into the newspaper is wrong.
马尔科姆·格拉德威尔，在“飞蛾”舞台上，人们来到那里讲述真实故事和偶尔的夸张故事。这个故事出现在“飞蛾”最伟大热点合集之一。他们的网站，那里有各种免费故事可以收听，是themoth.org。顺便说一下，如果这里有一点歧义，年轻记者请注意，把虚假信息放入报纸是错误的。
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, John Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Emily Youssef. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Special thanks today to Michael Purdy, Bradley Olsen, and Robert Krulwich.
我们的节目由罗宾·塞米恩制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·费尔特斯、约翰·杰特、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与制作。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥韦茨负责我们的网站。塞思·林德和艾米丽·优素福提供制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀提供音乐帮助。今天特别感谢迈克尔·珀迪、布拉德利·奥尔森和罗伯特·克鲁尔维奇。
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcast or listen to any of our old shows for absolutely free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says that he is absolutely certain that all these years doing the pledge drive must be good for something.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获得我们免费的每周播客或免费收听我们任何旧节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。本《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他说他绝对肯定这些年来做认捐活动一定对某些事情有好处。
I thought about it. I was like, I bet selling life insurance is way easier than this. Or like those guys who sell scissors, go door to door, like Cutco, they sell scissors. I'm like, I'm sure I can sell some scissors.
我想过。我想，我打赌卖人寿保险比这容易多了。或者像那些挨家挨户卖剪刀的人，像Cutco，他们卖剪刀。我想，我肯定能卖掉一些剪刀。
I'm Ira Glass. I'm back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周我会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。